hello YouTube chairs lovers in our
friends
this is grunge in here and welcome to
the 5th part of my chess reputa against
TV for now in this video I'm going to
build how to defuse the squash campus
if you recall my previous video at this
point when white respond with the Moody
fall here my recommendation was to play
the movie file and if white wants now he
can go back to the rim of scotch game
while this more and here I can play the
move Knight to f3 so in a way it's a
transposition to the scotch game and
black should know exactly how is going
to handle the squash game
before we look at the main squash lines
let me deal with the gambit ideas by
white and that is I'm going to cover in
this video
after across d4 white will play the move
Bishop to c4 and this is known as squash
gambit
now scotch gambit hasn't oftenly played
at the highest level but at the club
level it's a frequent member and the
simple reason is it has a tremendous
attacking power so that's why it's very
essential for you know how to handle
this stuff there are many different ways
scotch gambit can of course let me
demonstrate how this can be occurs in
different models first of all after
efore if black responds with the movie
file and after Knight f3 knight c6 now
comes the d4 and after across d4 and
Bishop to c4 we are back to the squash
gambit and this is probably the main
water the another way is efore ePHI
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 if I can start
with the Joko P online which is Bishop
to c4 and after black this pawn with the
move Bishop to c5 now white can play
this move which is d4
again we are back in the rims of the
Scotch campaign so you can see there are
plenty of ways I can trick back enter
into the Scotch cam bit more as a part
of my rap rota we are going to stick
with our main water which is after efore
n6 d4 d5 Knight to f3 across d4 and here
white plays the move Bishop to c4 at
this point I am recommending that blacks
should play the move Bishop to c5 so it
looks very natural because it's not only
developing a piece but it's also
protecting the spawn and here white has
few options now the main line is the
move c3 but there are other side lines
has been oftenly played which we are
going to look at the end of this video
so straight away let me enter to the
main line which occurs when white plays
the move c3 and now here I recommend
that we should play the move Knight to
f6 but before we enter the Knight to f6
let's see what kind of danger black can
fall into if black Grilli accept this
point so let's say V cross c3 why it has
a fantastic shot which is bishop cross
f7 and after King takes f7 and Queen to
defy check not only black lost the
castle ride but white will regain the
piece so please don't fall for this kind
of greedy trap Alliance and that's why I
am recommending the move Knight to f6 at
this point now again I have highlighted
by the arrows White has a few choices
the main line is the move e5 but before
we look at the main line let's look at
the side variations first the first move
which I want to cover is the move Bishop
to g5 which is not
but some of the people are still trying
and I don't know what the compensation
white gets after the move at 6:00 now
here if white takes this night let's say
Bishop cross f6 then Queen takes f6
black is completing his development but
meanwhile black all pcs are protecting
the d4 pawn and it's very hard for white
- you know regain the pond so I don't
consider this line is good for white
instead of Bishop captures f6 the other
move is Bishop to h4 but again I don't
believe in this line because black
hasn't castle on the King side black can
simply play the move g5 and after Bishop
to g3 black can cold-bloodedly capture
this pawn so all in all Bishop to g5 is
not a good move the second move white
can try is this tricky looking move
which is castle on the King side and
here I recommend that you should play
the move Knight takes e4 and do not
afraid of the pin so for example there
are two moves tried over here in first
game my opponent trial rook to even but
after very simple defy it's very hard to
believe that White has something for his
phone so the game continues with C cross
T 4 and after Bishop to b4 and Bishop to
b2 black and simply castle on the King
side the next move black can either play
Bishop to e6 Bishop to a5 or Bishop to
g4 depending on the circumstances and
please note that at this point black is
a clear part of
the other moot right at this point is C
cross v4 well here black has a very
tricky reply and let's start with the
move default main line goes like this so
T cross C Phi and D cross c4 and here
white has two choices now in the first
game my opponent try the main line stuff
which is the move Queen e2 who but
please remember this move from the black
perspective and this is very amazing
move which can diffuse the whole white
setup and that is the move Queen to b3
so immediately attacking the Queen and
the game goes like this so my opponent
try
rook to even and I responded with the
move f5 and now after Knight to c3
I simply castle on the King side and
after some captures
I played the move Bishop to a5 so
material is balanced at this point but
look at the tremendous activity from the
black perspective black has almost
activated all his minor pieces and on
the very next move white rook can come
to either D file or the e-file and look
at the white undone of pieces
so although material is balanced black
has a tremendous initiative
apart from Queen to e2 the second move
tried is Queen captures d8 and after
King captures now white plays the move
rook to deepen check and the game
continues like this so I played the move
Bishop to d7 and now black is
threatening to capture that pawn so my
opponent played the move Bishop to e3
I played the move King to e7 so now idea
is very simple if white wants to play
the move Knight to e3 attack the pawn on
c4 then black can simply reply with the
move Bishop to b6 protecting that one in
the game I upon and try the move Knight
B to d2 but after Knight captures Knight
and rook captures night I played the
move rook H to d8 and after rook a to c1
which has a matter of attacking my pawn
I can simply defend my pawn with the
move Bishop to e6 and now white is very
hard-pressed for the compensation in the
game my opponent desperately try this
move which is Knight to g5 but I
responded very very accurately so I
played the move rook captures rook and
after Bishop captures rook I hit that
bishop with my rook development and
after Bishop to e3
now I played the move Bishop to f5 so
please note not only black has defended
the h7 but white cannot capture this
pawn because there's a back leg mate
exist
my opponent tried to give his King a
left square so he played the move SV but
now the tasks become very very easy for
black so black plays the move f6 which
has a merit of attacking the knight and
after Knight to f3 Bishop to b6 black
can finally manage to hold on to that
pawn and the game so that is about Queen
captures Queen with this lines we can
easily conclude that at this point
castling on the King side is not at all
good for white and black can simply
reply with the capturing the a pawn and
remain upon up in the rest of the game
the third move i want to consider where
here is c captures d4
and now black has to throw this check
which is Bishop to b4 check here there
are two main moves the first rubbish
moves Knight to c3 which is a some kind
of gambit idea but I don't believe in
this gambit ideas because black can
simply capture this pawn and asking
Wyatt to show his compensation well here
the line continues with the castle on
the Kings side so inviting black to
capture the knight with his own Knight
where some of the Nights tricks
exists for the white side but we are not
fall into this kind of tricks instead of
that we are going to simply capture this
Knight with the bishop and again if
simply recapture the bishop there
the move defy is very strong and black
will be a pawn off for the rest of the
game that means white has to try out his
tricky path and it continues with the MU
D file you can see right now blacks two
pieces are hanging now here there are
few variations amongst them Knight to e5
as a strongest of all but it leads to a
very complicated play so instead of this
I like the old traditional move and that
is the move Bishop back to the f6 and
this line completely diffused this setup
now White has to regain his piece back
so there are two ways white can go for
it so the first obvious way is to
immediately capture on c6 afterwards
black will recapture with the B pole and
after rook to even black has a very
simple answer castling on the Kings side
and at first sight it looks like black
has given up the piece but after rook
captures knight black can regain the
piece via the move d5
instead of D crosses six the another
tricky line is look to even so again
black has two pieces are hanging and
again black is going to play a very safe
move and that is night two itself
allowing Y to capture this night and
then black will respond with the move d6
if you look at the position carefully
black has a compact bone structure and
not only there black is a clear point up
so if Y it does not demonstrate anything
over here then white is completely
losing this game
accordingly white has to play this move
Bishop to g5 idea is to double the black
pawn so black this pulse is pretty much
force black has to capture this bishop
and after Knight recaptured black can
easily castle on the King side in
Whiting white to play his tricky move
which is Queen to h5 which threatening a
checkmate but just one move that is
Bishop to a5 and Blackberry all the
thread and remain upon up after rook to
e2 Bishop to g6 and Queen to f3 black
and respond with the move Knight where
fire not only at this point black is
hitting the night but black is also
clear born with no problem at all
so that is about the gambit idea of
Knight to c3
at this point the main move is Bishop to
d2 Bishop to b2 is a very tricky move
because is inviting Knight takes e4
which is exactly I'm going to recommend
but the following variation is very very
important to understand because not only
white will regain the pawn but white
will have some kind of a key position
the line runs like this so after Knight
takes e4 White is going to capture this
Bishop and after Knight recaptured now
White is going to give this Shaq Bishop
cross Epsilon and after king recapture
white will play the move Queen to b3 but
still I believe that this line is very
good for black and if you check out with
any computers it will show you that
black has a plus position so let me show
you how black should continue over here
so here black should play the move D
file and after Queen recaptures now
black should play the move rook to e8
trying to get a discovery to the White
King so white has two castle on the King
side afterwards black has to play the
move c6
so not only consolidating the d5 pawn
but in some lines Queen has this excess
on this either b6 or the e5 square here
the line continues with the move Knight
to e4 check and after King to g8 Knight
to c3 has been tried but against this
the very simple apply from the black
perspective is to play Queen to b6 and
going for the Queen trade because this
Queen trade can
only help black so the game continues
like this so after white capture the
knight and black recapture yes black
indeed get this isolated pawn but that
can be very easily defendable as the
game continues you will see that can be
turn out as an asset so in this game
white ride the move rook even
immediately attacking the e4 but after
Bishop to e6 so now if white capture the
e4 then black captures on a two so white
defended with the move a3 but after
Bishop to defy yes White has managed to
post his knight on a beautiful square
but so did as a black and this position
it's roughly balanced so black will have
no problem at all in this line with this
we have concluded all the side
variations now we are going back to the
main line that is the move e5